One area where quantum computing might improve machine learning
is related to colonel functions or
colonel matrices let's explore what those are
and why we need them to do this will remind ourselves of
three things why do dot products show up in machine learning
why do machine learning problems involve higher dimensions
and what are kernel functions
recall that the dot product or inner product of
real indimensional vectors a
and b is given by the product of asemagnitude
and bees magnitude and the co sign of fate at the angle
between them this is equivalent to multiplying
each component of a by the corresponding component of
b and something note that if the victors are
nearly orthogonal such as when a
has zero components where b has large ones
the dot product is small this is equivalent to
fatah approaching pie over two
similarly if a has negative components would be
has positive components
meaning the vectors point in
nearly opposite directions
and state as close to pie
the result of the dot product could be
negative finally if a has large components where b
also has large components of the same sign
so the vectors are nearly parallel in fate is around zero
the dot product will be large
and positive so it's very reasonable to expect that dot products
will be a useful measure of similarity
in data points not all indimensional data
can be easily separated in an end minus
one dimensional cut meaning a line
plane or hyperplane when the data are not well separated
in end dimensions we can embed the data points
in higher dimensions say m dimensions where m
is greater than end this is called a feature mapping
often denoted as x going to five x where
five x is a mapping from indimensional real numbers to
m dimensional real numbers
this is easiest to picture when
bending a set of one dimensional data up into
two dimensions or taking two dimensional data
and embedding it in three dimensions
but in reality we often embed data in spaces with thousands
or even millions of dimensions
a dot product of three dimensional vectors compared to a dot
product of two dimensional vectors is an insignificant difference
but a dot product of a million dimensional vectors
becomes completely intractable
to apply to a large data set
so people came up with a clever trick
what if you used a projection
into higher dimensions that is a very specific form
such that the dot products of vectors in
higher dimensions are a simple function of the
lower dimensional vectors that is we find a mapping
from our data x to higher dimensional fire acts
such that the inner product in
feature space is given by a
simple function in the lower dimensional data.
This function k is called a colonel function
ideally we would like this colonel function
to be a function of the lower dimensional
inner product itself that would give us the
best of both worlds a very high dimensional feature space
but with a cheap and easy to calculate in our product
at first glance it may not
be obvious that this is even possible let's look at
one simple example in very low dimensions
considered this specific feature mapping it maps a
three dimensional vector into a
nine dimensional space it turns out
that the inner product of the nine dimensional feature mapped
space is simply given by the inner product in the original
three d space squared so the inner product
of the mapped space using the five functions
would require the calculation of each of the
nine coordinates for the
first vector and nine for the
second then the inner product itself which is
another nine products and some
that's a total of twenty eight operations
the colonel function requires three products
and to some corresponding to just four operations
that was for mapping a three dimensional data point into
nine dimensional feature space
it's easy to see that this could be highly advantageous
for very large spaces.
The colonel function is typically a continuous function
that you can apply to any vector in your dataset
but we use colonel functions by taking
pairs of data points from our set
as the arguments applying a colonel function to
each pair of data points in the set
results in a symmetric matrix called the colonel
matrix the type of colonel function you'll use depends on
your problem so to recap
describing the similarity of vectors in our datasets
often requires inner products in our products in
very high dimensional feature space become expensive
so we use feature mappings corresponding
to certain special colonel functions
than make the calculation more efficient
but this restriction to special colonel functions
does restrict what sorts of mappings into feature space can
be done efficiently this
may prevent us from separating our data well
if only there were another way
this is work one of computing comes in
the very high dimensional feature mapping corresponding
to colonel functions can be carried out
on a quantum computer in the quandom colonel estimator
the colonel matrix k is calculated
and from there a classical machine learning algorithm can be
used to accomplish this one data point x one
is loaded and mapped and then
another x two is loaded
and mapped since the inner product of two quantum states
is related to the measurement probability
we can estimate the inner product of the two mapped
data points by making sufficiently many measurements of
the resulting circuit in this way are circuit
can tell us about an inner product
in any high dimensional space that the circuit can model
without our ever classically calculating an inner product or
colonel function there are many ways of
customising and enhancing these methods
and indeed there are always new methods being proposed
and tested we hope this
overview has been helpful in framing the
application of quantum computing
to machine learning methods
especially those involving colonels